en fait une interview alors fait
l'interview on change de place en charge
de placer l'interview morts
thierry ardisson se souviens tu de la
tour zizim dacquois latour zizim non
c'est un bourganeuf
mais je suis jamais vécu à bourganeuf
dans son bar et non tu connais pas code
postal non plus non 23 c 23 400 te
souviens tu déjà bien non si les petits
gâteaux qu'ils mangeaient mers-el-kébir
non moins évident qu'il aime la bière
alors thierry souviens-tu 2000 on peut
tu as vite non mais si l'eau mais si
c'est le nom je place de l'étudiant
c'est la page des essais la plage des
jeunes à lille sur l'île de yo se
souvient pas si c'est vrai et je suis en
plein dans la plage bongo studer est ce
que tu te souviens de toi avant de
s'habiller en noir
oui alors je te dis en gris foncé mais
n'ont pas toujours si si ça mérite à
période entre gris clair et gris foncé
tirèrent dix ans que vous vous souvenez
d'une robe de votre mère voit une robe à
fleurs aux crotone quelle couleur des
grosses fleurs rouges
est ce que vous vous souvenez la
première photo de votre première photo
dans un journal
oui il y avait un mec avait gagné une
course de ski dans un petit village où
j'habite en savoie mais c'est moi qui
était en couverture du journal parce que
j'avais à embrouiller le journaliste est
ce que tu te souviens de ton jouet
préféré reporter habite bien sûr
enfants en fait je comprends ce soir
c'est un peu aussi l'auteur de nice hier
à six mois je vous invite eh bien oui je
mérite une talbot lago avec laquelle je
jouais est ce que tu te souviens de
george harrison
ouais j'ai rencontré au george 5 et là
bas rien parce qu'en fait quand on
rencontre des gens qu'on admire vraiment
il se passe pas grand chose en fait on
leur dit qu'on les admire à hélices très
bien et puis voilà quoi ils s'en foutent
est ce que tu te souviens des taxes papa
oui c'est dire que chaque fois que mes
enfants présents le dessert je taxe une
cuillère et jordi donc taxe soit pas ces
normes
tu sais que tu dis il ya deux types de
femmes dans la ville et mère protectrice
et les [ __ ] te souviens-tu de
laquelle lesquels je préfère ça dépend
des moments où ça démange et maman se
souvient tous de l'île dardy de talia et
laetitia oui linda hardy ont tiré les
rois tu t'en souviens le moment de
passer sous la table pour dire qu'à quai
à qui était la part elle l'a mal pris et
talia titia épiphanie il fait nuit elle
rien on pourra y est une ballade
oui très bien je me suis un très bien
d'elle surtout titia qu'elle soit si tu
me regardes tu aurais pu te souviens tu
tires et pour finir uniquement de ce qui
te dérange
non ce qui t'arrange aussi oui ce qui
m'arrange je m'en souvienne da ce qui me
dérange je m'en souviens pas t'en
souviens tu de tes rêves d'enfants oui
d'être là merci bien sorti tu peux
europe leur faire quand tu veux voilà